[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's an obstacle to freedom if now we
need a virus pass to fetch groceries go
to the cinema or enjoy life after a
grueling job
the virus past is a real danger for
everybody it's really an
anti-social thing we are creating a
segregated society and i think it's
unbelievable to be doing this
in the country of human rights i've
never protested before in my life
but i think our freedom is in danger
[Music]
so i am a nurse and i've resigned
because i think we mustn't be
blackmailed
i also think that we shouldn't be told
what to do
[Music]
in france in particular people read as a
violation of
egalite the important pillar of we are
all equal
and no one is a second-class citizen
just because he or she decides
against vaccination which brings up a
problem with
solidarity which is the fraternity
pillar of their system
because there are risk groups that need
to be protected from those who think
it's their personal choice whether they
do something for society or not